hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and I
am Malcolm right and this is Tamra's
never seen Cameron Malcolm never seen so
today we're doing Blair Witch the 1999
version and then Blair Witch the 2016
version so we're gonna just tackle them
one at a time yeah I guess compare and
contrast and and we're both very excited
we're gonna hair flip yeah Malcolm knows
the drill I do I got phone call so
what's good Oh cameras never seen time
towba first wasn't very good okay guys
so we have watched both the movies and I
think first we should talk about the
1999 yeah
version in order the original one uh I
don't know what you I thought it was
boring yeah it was boring it was boring
but it's like one of the first found
footage films like really to you know
establish itself as a genre you know
right and um you know it's a cool
concept you know it's like film students
we're going out and we're gonna you know
do a documentary about this lords Blair
Witch and right which they spent a lot
of time and marketing in I'm developing
that like is this really he thought it
was real I love that aspect yeah I love
the hype
yeah the hype is really cool and because
now I feel like that couldn't happen
with the Internet
yeah sort of kind of I mean a few years
ago it happened with Paranormal Activity
it kind of kind of yeah similar
another kind of thing I just I just
remember this coming out I mean not
being allowed to watch the same saying
saying oh you know these kids died in
the forest so the first one the actors
are are good yeah the girl is the lead
Heather yeah she kind of got on my
nerves but I think their character is
supposed to bury yeah she's like we must
get this footage we we have to get the
film made right Mary problem we know
people like that yep I found myself
wanting to see more though I liked the
tension it built by not seeing yeah yeah
you're definitely left like wanting
wanting wanting you know it peak speak
speak speaks but there's never any
payoff the end is show on to me they're
in the house or whatever and the guy
that she's with is like huddled in the
corner yeah really yeah no he's like
standing like Ethel like just staring at
the wall and she's like calling out his
name I think and then she just collapses
yeah I think she collapses or she just
drops the camera and she's like oh yeah
yeah oh whose house is it like why is it
yeah I don't get it I guess I guess they
were so focused on the concept of you
know it could be real we don't need to
explain ourselves in well you kind of
have to write a story though feed it to
us but at least likely was like hints I
don't think there are enough things yeah
didn't really know were the creepy
things happening though like the um you
know whatever the twig things and the
forest were there camping like a pile of
rocks yeah we beam the goo when there
was some goo on their stuff yeah yeah
yeah that was cool and like they they
kind of toyed a little bit with the idea
of them kind of like losing their sanity
a little yes
yeah hysteria yeah which I enjoy because
I mean that you like loss it's
terrifying like it's such a terrifying
idea reach it and they like we're
messing around like them like going in a
circle but honestly it's like why did
they follow the creepy anyone like man
like it leads to something yeah not a
circle Creek yeah please here if River
we're at Six Flags behold fungi Barry
Kane are right he's the way today is
ahead your season I didn't hate it yeah
I didn't hate it I I thought it was you
know enjoyable up to that point just
didn't I wish it would have went
somewhere delivered just like a little
bit I was going into it expecting
nothing I thought I was really not gonna
like it yeah same same and I found
myself enjoying it as it was you know
picking up I'm like okay where's this
going right I could see this is cool
it's a slow crawl but it's bleeding
somewhere but the student filmmakers
themselves like they had black-and-white
footage representing what was you know
going to be their documentary and the
color footage was there behind the
scenes I thought that was a good way to
keep track of you know what was what
definitely so that was creative I like
yeah I was excited to see the second one
because I heard that you did see some
thing of the witch like you saw a little
bit yeah I miss explained more yeah and
they were like they continued the story
on really well and then I heard people
like people at Facebook were like I
wasn't not good but a couple people like
Walter from awesome comics was like oh
yeah like it's it's not that great but
like the end is scary and like how's it
going well I'm excited to see it it's
gonna be interesting mmm especially
since I expected nothing from the first
and I liked it yeah I didn't like hate
it at least I him I was like excited
same saying uh we're talking about a
2016 1 yeah no I was like pumped to go
see this one
um you know there was just like some you
know scheduling conflicts and like um I
ended up seeing though Hey I eventually
ended up seeing the film it was oh god I
just sat up and there's a lot of care in
it in the air so the 2016 lot lots more
characters yeah way more characters than
I felt necessary uh-huh I don't even
know any of their names I mean this is
almost weird
well the his friends had a like a she's
in film school and she had to do a
documentary style thing and so she was
like let's continue the story course of
course thanks super down and which I
think it's a cool way to continue it
yeah yeah so somebody uploaded some
footage on YouTube I had no report and
so they were like let's go figure out
where they film it so they go to find
those people and they get to the people
and the people are like well you just
take us with you if you're gonna go out
into those woods we're coming too and so
then it's like even more people it's a
lot of characters that I didn't really
care to get to know like there was no
real fleshing out of the characters it's
just a bunch of kids yeah like we're the
high school or college buddies maybe
like first year college
yeah but then like very like all
shot-for-shot like in the first movie I
remember this shot where they're leaving
their car to go into the woods and they
keep the camera on the car for a long
time and I thought it was so odd yeah
okay it's like car it's being left
behind right it's like they do the same
thing in the 2016 version I thought that
was cool although like unnecessary like
they just should have been in the first
one but they do similar things with like
the you know whatever twig guys and I
yeah formations yeah and I don't know I
guess I'm just trying to figure out what
he did differently in this film
something that I liked that was
different in the newer one is that there
was like a time loop aspect yeah yeah
there was that aspect I like that effect
to the camera - like yeah additions and
stuff they finally left the two people
that we're going to show them those
things and they left to get help and
then they ran into him again in the
forest and and they were like how long
has it been since we saw us and and the
people are like this it's like this
morning we saw you and they were like no
it's been five days since we saw you
differently yeah leaves four different
characters two things cool it was
introducing another aspect that was that
previously there which is I guess they
like hinted at it a bit in the first one
with like they said like the day's
lasted forever and so like it was me I
like that that's horrifying
to be like yes like I'm know yeah like
the drone shot or they're like trying to
find their way out in the drone goes up
and there's no Street you know like
trails or anything I'm like well you
don't know where you are and you don't
know what time is right now so yeah that
was yeah that is kind of cool it gets
really confusing though at points like
something happens and they start
screaming and then the camera goes
ballistic it's just like all over the
place I'm like yeah it takes me right
out of it I'm like okay you're shaking
the camera so I don't just like I'm like
what's happening for sure I'm like dart
door soldier audience me we know it's a
found footage film but yummy if you're
just gonna shake the camera at us
I mean literally it's just like yeah you
got like a bigger budget you got yeah
you got notoriety you got the internet
there's like that scene where that one
of the girls like breaks the little
stick figure thing it happened yeah girl
just like breaks in half yeah yeah like
she dies I was like oh are these like
voodoo twig dolls right but the nest of
the last you hear of that yes seems like
there's just a lot of like plots
happening I was talking to Jim about the
or media's Walter about the the girl got
the injury in her foot I thought that
was supposed to be like a worm yeah it
was yeah it was supposed to be wood
Walter was saying this that it's so she
would and you know the witch creature at
the end with like the pointy like legs
and whatever yeah she's supposed to be
turning into one of those and like oh
that was like a big like a big splinter
coming
her yeah it was like a big splinter and
so that's what he was hinting at but
that was never well I never I thought it
was a book I don't like a bug earlier or
something house like that's creepy but
why I did enjoy that she got I mean I
did enjoy but like a part that she got
injured because then it that was like
the start of like everything yeah
happening with that was like okay yeah
okay this takes a little yeah heightens
the stakes
like everything that happens it just
kind of like ends up you know kind of
falling short they make it to the house
we have a five the house and the brother
thinks that he hears Heather C's Heather
or whatever anything well it's been 20
years so no yeah no it's probably not
Heather
she hasn't been living in the woods for
20 years mmm-hmm oh yeah unless there
was like that time true on that would
have been amazing see we're connecting
pieces of what they should have doing
right kind of looks like and like your
point of view in like a haunted house
yes going around which was cool that was
cool but then there's the scene where
the girl like crawls through this mud
yeah high tunnel yeah like there's two
solid minute yeah it's just crawl yeah
and you see like a light through that
looks like a light at the end of the
tunnel and you're like okay so was she
climbing out of a well and why is she
climing how does she get I don't know
where this out okay brother
quiet Wiggy what talking to Pat only
talking affairs she went no one pays
attention to her she just yells oh say
hi Duncan
Wendy oh ho you had to get like I'm
gonna get Stern and she's like okay okay
okay this is Wendy hmm she's pretty too
okay there's just so many instances
instances in this movie that it could
have been way scarier and I wasn't ever
scared watching this but one another
part like that is that she's up there
with the guy and they're like in the
Attic or whatever and he's like if you
don't look at the way
she can't get you and then he looks at
her yeah I mean it's just whoopsies yeah
I thought it was really cool that she's
like looking in her camera to see behind
her to see where she's walking hmm and I
was saying this to the guys at the
studio is like usually in scary movies
when people are screaming in a situation
like this I'm like oh my shot ah just
stop screaming
but this one I was like I mean all she's
do is not look at the witch the Witch
know she's there already so you could
scream all you want right like if I saw
much behind me and I'm like walking
backwards and I'm just seeing her like
right behind you I scream so loud oh are
you can write and I thought that was
cool and scary then she looks like she's
stuck and she like turns and then she
yeah for some reason something makes her
turn around I didn't get it though oh
yeah was it a voice oh yeah because the
guy is like I'm so sorry whatever your
name is
then she hears the exact same sound
bites but it was also the wish training
here I guess very confusing yeah messy
yes it's extremely messy like I I think
that's a good way to describe it is yeah
that's good because he like takes us
like it tries to draw us in but it's
just such a mess with all these
characters and introducing these new
rules and yeah shaky cameras yeah and
screaming screaming scream you scream so
much yelling yeah what she was going
through the tunnel the noises she was
making and like you didn't see her so I
just imagined it's just like a voiceover
so I just imagine her in from this mic
just yeah I think we're all facing like
yep that's it yes that's the tape that's
the one that's the magic lightning in a
bottle I always wonder when things like
that happen if the actor watches the
movie cuz you know of course you get
other tapes oh yeah you'd be most oh
it's like I wonder if she watches it
it's like that's the one they went with
the wine is I know I do that sometimes
I'm like I can't believe yeah pretty
sure overall that's what do you think
overall I like the first one better the
first one it was more solid a tighter
tighter cast they all delivered their
roles well enough and I understood the
basic plot even though I didn't lead to
anything I still understood what was
going on do a degree in the second one I
just didn't know what was going on and I
like checked out so many times I'm like
let me rewind that just in case I missed
something and it turned out I did I wish
that the first one had more of the time
loop aspect yeah and I wish that it
obviously that it led to somewhere but I
do think I liked the first one better to
just this the second like it tried he
crammed in its I just stopped yeah cuz I
do really like the Lord that I created
around her yeah there's a Great Lord but
I feel like I mean like we can make our
own language yeah yes is good honestly
everything I couldn't tell the bar oh oh
it's so boring
as always to type oh you know you're
fine
oh okay I don't want ever missing that
I'm like holding you get your will so
you have to come
oh yeah just like I'm out I mean no
injures in this terrible children oh
that is what we thought of Blair Witch
1999 and 2016 if we could do another
team up for like a single movie I think
it'd be better if we did like a what
what do you think it should be yeah let
let us know in the comments something
that I don't wanna be fun to do
something that we could both like it
might be one of the characters for right
like make a little mini parody yourself
yes yeah yes so give us your ideas let
us know what you like yeah cuz I haven't
seen a lot of stuff either right I'm not
the only one okay bye guys yeah thanks
for having me
you